اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله وفيه نتابع تغطيه
التطورات في الضفه الغربيه بعد اقتحام
جنين
احتلال تقرروا تمديد اقتحام جنين ومخيمها
في عمليه هي الاوسع منذ عام 2002 وتقول
انها لم تحقق اهدافها بعد وتجبر مئات
العائلات من سكان المدينه على المغادره
وبعد مواجهات محتدمه شارك فيها الف جندي
الاسرائيلي ومروحيات استشهاد ثمانيه في
جنين واخر في البيره
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تعلن اسقاط ثلاث
مسيرات وتفجير اليات خلال التوغل
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه تعلن تعليق الاتصالات
مع الاسرائيليين والاستمرار في وقف
التنسيق الامني في تصريحات للجزيره نائب
رئيس المكتب السياسي لحماس يقول ان الحركه
انذرت اسرائيل عبر وسطاء من رد شامل اذا
تجاوزت الخطوط الحمراء بجنين ونائب الامين
العام للجهاد الاسلامي يؤكد ان فصائل
المقاومه موحده في موقفها بشان التصدي
لتصعيد الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
ومع تتابع الادانات العربيه والدوليه
الامم المتحده تطالب تل ابيب بوقف الهجمات
على المناطق السكنيه ومناسقها لعمليه
السلام يقول انه تواصل مع جميع الاطراف من
اجل التهدئه وبعد تاكيد البيت الابيض دعما
ما سماه حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها
الخارجيه الامريكيه تدعو لاتخاذ اجراءات
احترازيه لمنع سقوط مدنيين
[موسيقى]
اذا ما زلنا في استطلاع ابعاد وتداعيات
الهجوم الاسرائيليه على جنين ومخيمها
ففيما يبدو تمهيدا لتصعيد اكبر خلال ساعات
الليل قامت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل
قليل باحتلال عشرات المباني في مخيم جنين
بعد اجبار مئات العائلات على اخلائها
وهددتها بالقصف وياتي هذا بعد قرار بتمديد
العمليه حيث قال مسؤولون عسكريون
اسرائيليون انها لم تحقق كل اهدافها
تطورا ياتي بعد يوم طويل من المواجهات
المحتدمه في مدينه جنين والتي دفعت فيها
قوات الاحتلال بنحو الف جندي وبقوات بريه
وبسلاح الجو في عمليه قال الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انها تهدف لاجتثاف المقاومه
ونذهب مباشره الان الى سمير ابو شمال ينضم
الينا من جنين سمير ماذا لديك
سلمى كما تشاهدين خلفي مباشره هناك دوريات
واليات عسكريه بدات بالدخول لاحدى المحاور
التابعه لمخيم جنين وتقوم مصطحبه بذلك
جرافات عسكريه للدخول الى مخيم جنين بعد
الساعه الاخيره التي شهدت عمليه اجلاء
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف مواطن فلسطيني مجبرين
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه من
منازلهم في احياء متعدده في مخيم جنين
وتحديدا عند اسفل حي الجابريات والهدف وفي
جوره الذهب وفي ساحه او في وسط مخيم جنين
تحديدا كان هناك مناشه مطالبات من قبل جيش
الاحتلال باجبار الى هذه العائلات وتحديد
زمن محدد هو نصف ساعه باخلاء منازلهم
وتركها بشكل عاجل وايضا الذهاب الى اماكن
اكثر
وقد لجا لجات هذه العائلات الفلسطينيه
التي لم تاخذ معها اي شيء من بيتها وقد
خرجت خاويه
خاويه على عروشها وليس معها اي شيء من
المستلزماتها وايضا من مستندات ابنائهم
ومستندات وهناك ايضا كان الناس ناس
مواطنين كبار السن ومرضى ايضا كان قد قد
تم اخلائهم اجبارا وقصرا من بيوتهم
والذهاب الى المناطق الاكثر امنا وكان اول
نقطه للذهاب كانت هي مستشفى
او ساحات مستشفى جنين الحكومي وايضا كان
هناك مناشدات عبر مكبرات الصوت في مساجد
المخيم وفي مدينه جنين بالذهاب الى
المساجد الاكثر امانا خارج مخيم جنين
وهناك ايضا بلديه البلديه قد ناشدت
المواطنين بانها ستفتح المركز الكوري
التابع لها وذلك لاستقبال هذه الاعداد
الكبيره من الفلسطينيين الذين خرجوا
اجبارا من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تحدث بانه قد
اخلف نحو 3000 فلسطيني حتى الان ولكن
العدد هو مرشح للزياده وهناك صعوبه بعمليه
اخلاء هؤلاء المواطنين وذلك جراء العمليات
التدميريه التي قامت بها جرافات الاحتلال
الاليات العسكريه الايطاليه في الكثير من
الشوارع والساحات الخاصه بالمخيم وقد اعاق
ذلك عمليات التحرك من المواطنين ايضا
الاسعافات داخل المخيم لاجلاء هذه
العائلات الى ما كان اكثر امنا الجيش
الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو يحاول الاستفراد
ببعض المسلحين الذين ما زالوا متواجدين في
داخل مخيم جنين حسب ما افدنا به من شهود
العيال قبل قليل كنا نتحدث عن بعض مع بعض
العائلات التي تركت بيتها وقد قد قالت لنا
ان هناك نقاط عسكريه كثيفه مكثفه في
طريقها عند خروجها من المخيم وقد تم
احتجاز زوج احدى السيدات التي تم اخلاؤها
من من بيتها احتجازه عند الجيش الاسرائيلي
دون اي سبب ولكن مضت بطريقها هي واولاده
واطفالها حتى وصلت الى احد الفنادق في
مدينه جنو على اطراف مخيم جنين وبالتالي
هذه الحاله الانسانيه هي حاله صعبه ومعقده
لدى الفلسطينيين الذين هم يتعرضون لهذه
المسلسل التعسفي من قبل ق وات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه نعم نشاهد الصوره من حيث انت
وهي يعني تظهر كما قلت لنا في البدايه
عمليه دخول لاليات كما نتابع من هذه الصور
المباشره لاحد المحاور الى اين يؤدي الى
اين يقود هذا المحور وما هو اسمه ويبدو
بان هناك مدنيين لا زالوا هناك يعني عند
المدرعات واليات الجيش ضعنا في كل هذه
المعطيات ان كان لديك
نعم سلمى هذه الاليات العسكريه هي منذ
صباحي هذا اليوم وهي تتمركز في هذا المكان
ولكن في الساعه الاخيره كان هناك اعاده
انتشار للاليات العسكريه والتنقلت الى ما
محاور اخرى هذا المحور وهذا الشارع هو
ياتي عند المدخل الشرقي لمخيم جنين حيث
تحاصر قوات الاحلال وتنشر الاليات
العسكريه بشكل مكثف عند هذا المحور منذ
بدء هذه العمليه العسكريه وتحاول حصار
وتطويق على الفلسطينيين من داخل المخيم
هذا الصوت الذي سمعتموه وهو ربما يكون
عباره عن تفجير عبوه محليه الصنع في احدى
الاليات العسكريه الجرافه العسكريه
المصاحبه لهذه الاليات العسكريه هي تعمل
وتنشط في الشوارع الفرعيه الاخرى تمهيدا
لدخول هذه الاليات على ما يبدو الى داخل
وعمق المخيم وذلك لتنفيذ والتكثيف العمل
العسكري داخل المخيم اسمح لي شاهدنا
مجموعه من النساء
اذا يعني يحملنا اطفالهن ويغادرن هل هي
عمليات مغادره كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
المباشره
نعم كما كنا نتحدث هذه عمليه اجبار
الفلسطينيين لمغادره بيوتهم والتوجه الى
الاماكن الاكثر امانا من قبلهم وكان هناك
عمليات
استغاثه من قبل
المؤسسات وايضا المساجد لفتح بيوت
الفلسطينيين في المناطق الاكثر امانا لهذه
العائلات التي تم اجبارها وتشريدها من
داخل بيوتها والخارجيه الفلسطينيه في بيان
قبل قليل دارت هذا هذه الجريمه جريمه طرد
وتاجير المدنيين الفلسطينيين من بيوت
مطالبه بتدخل دولي عاجل لوقف هذه السياسه
التعسفيه والتي وصفتها بالهمجيه اتجاه
الفلسطينيين من خلال تهجيرهم واجبارهم
قصرا على اخلاء بيوتهم وذلك تمهيدا على ما
يبدو لارتكاب مجزره جديده ضد الفلسطينيين
وتحديدا ضد المسلحين التابعين للفصائل
المشرحه اذا اخراجهم من بيوتهم يعني
بطريقه اجباريه ما الذي تقوم به بالمقابل
قوات الاحتلال
بالمنازل التي
اخليت من سكانها يعني عمدا
يعني حسب ما افدنا به من شهادات الاعيان
الذين قد خرجوا مجبرين من بيوت تحدثوا بان
القوات الاحتلال هي دهمت بيوتهم وقد عثت
فيها فسادا وخربتها وايضا اعتقلت عددا
محتجزت عددا من المواطنين الفلسطينيين
وايضا عملت ثغرات في الجدران هذا هذه
المنازل وذلك لاستخدامها من قبل القناصه
الجنود القناصه التبعين لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والذين يرصدون كل تحرك
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين وبالتالي هذه
المنازل اصبحت هي ثكنات عسكريه لجيش
الاحتلال بعد افراغها من سكانها في الساعه
الاخيره وبالتالي هذا ربما ينذر بتكثيف
الجهد العسكري والعمليه العسكريه اتجاه
المسلحين الفلسطينيين في بعض المناطق
المحدوده في داخل مخيم جنين وتحديدا في
قلب المخيم وعند الاطراف الخاصه بحي
الجابريات والهدف وايضا الكاميرا
تحركت من تلك الزاويه الى شارع اخر هذا
الشارع هو في ذات المحور الذي نتحدث عنه
المحور الشرقي الذي يذهب باتجاه مخيم جنين
نعم بكل تاكيد سلمى نحن نتحدث عن مخيم
جنين وهو يقع على مساحه نصف كيلو متر مربع
وهو
ذوك كثافه سكانيه عاليه وهناك شوارع وازقه
هي تؤدي الى داخل العمق هذا المخيم
وبالتالي الشوارع كلها تؤدي الى هذا
المخيم من خلال اي اتجاه ربما تدخلي
تدخل الاليات العسكريه من محاور مختلفه
سواء محاور الاطراف الغربيه او الشرقيه او
حتى الجنوبيه وتقوم بعمليات الاقتحام
المخيم الذي شهدناه على مدار ساعات الفجر
الاولى من هذا اليوم والتي كثفت من خلالها
وبدات من خلالها القوات الاسرائيليه
باقتحام هذا المخيم ولكن بمساعده ومسانده
من قبل الطائرات والمسيرات الهجوميه التي
هي استهدفت بعض المواقع قبل دخول القوات
البريه والاليات العسكريه التي اصطحب
اصطحبت بكل تاكيد هذه الجرافات العسكريه
المصفحه التي قامت بتخريب البناء التحتيه
حتى الشوارع دمرتها وخربتها وايضا دمرت
هذه البنى التحتيه
بالمناسبه بلديه جنين هي اوقفت جميع
الخدمات الخاصه بالمياه والكهرباء نتيجه
هذه العمليات التدميريه والتخريبيه التي
قامت بها هذه الجرافات ودمرت عبر التحذير
الخاصه بشبكات المياه والكهرباء في بعض
المناطق الخاصه في داخل المخيم ستبقى معنا
وصوره تبقى معنا ولكن اذهب الى الياس كرام
الياس هل هناك اي اعلانات من قبل
العمليات في جانب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن
تحركات ربما في الساعات القادمه باتجاه
المخيم
الجيش الاسرائيلي يتكتم حول تحركاته
العسكريه ولا يكشفها على الملا ولا يتحدث
عنها ولا يصدر بشانها بيانات خاصه تشير
الى نوع العمليات العسكريه او تحديدا
التحركات العسكريه داخل المخيم لكن هنالك
ما يؤكد من قبل شهود عيان ومن قبل ايضا
بعض مقاطع الفيديو التي تصل تباعا بان
هنالك قوات عسكريه اسرائيليه كبيره بدات
تدخل منطقه جنين هي قوات جديده تضاف الى
القوات التي تعمل منذ اكثر من 20 ساعه في
داخل مدينه جنين وفي داخل مخيمها هذا ربما
يكون مؤشرا على تعزيز القوات العسكريه في
جنين وربما استبدال للقوات التي تعمل منذ
20 ساعه في داخل المخيم بمعنى انه قد نشهد
الان انسحابا جزئيا او معينا لبعض القوات
العامله في المخيم جنين الى المواقع
العسكريه القريبه والمتاخمه الى الخط
الاخضر مقابل الزج بوحدات قتاليه جديده
الى داخل المخيم وهذا يعني بان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحاول الان تجديده
الدماء الموجوده في داخل بين جنودها او
تعزيز الوجود العسكري مقابل اراحه الجنود
الذين عملوا منذ ساعات فجر يوم امس في حين
ان المقاتلين الفلسطينيين المحاصرين ليس
لديهم اي وقت للراحه في ضوء هذا العمل
العسكري المتواصل والضغط العسكري المتواصل
ايضا من جانب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهذا ما
يمنح قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تفوقا حتى
في هذه الناحيه بمعنى انه هو قادر على
اراحه جنوده ووحداته العامله في الميدان
لكن المقاتلين الفلسطينيين هم تحت ضغط
شديد ومتواصل حتى هذه الساعه مع مرور اكثر
من 20 ساعه على بدء هذه القوات العسكريه
التي دخلت في الساعات في الدقائق الاخيره
هي كما نشاهد صور لجيبات عسكريه
ولمصفحات لناقلات جند من نوع النمر هذه
القوات المصفحه التي تدخل ايضا الى المخيم
وتعزز الوجود العسكري هناك واضح بان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تسعى في الساعات
القليله المقبله ربما الى تكثيف عملياتها
العسكريه داخل مخيم وما يفسر هذا هو ايضا
عمليه اجلاء السكان الواسعه من داخل مخيم
جنين وهذا يمنح قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ربما حريه العمل داخل المخيم وتكثيف وتصيد
عملياته العسكريه سواء كان ذلك البريه
منها وسواء كان ذلك ايضا الجويه لان الان
القوات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تحت جنح
الظلام بامكانها ان تتحرك ربما بسهوله
اكبر ساعات النهار هذا لكانها ربما لا
تكون مكشوفه اكثر بالنسبه لقوه المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين الموجودين في المخيم وبطبيعه
الحال لدى جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا
وسائل الرؤيا الليليه التي تمكنهم من
العمل بسلاسه اكبر وبحريه اكبر تحت جنح
الظلام وفي داخل الازرقاء
[موسيقى]
هذا طبعا عن المسيرات والسلاح الطيران نعم
نحن لا زلنا نشاهد هذه الصور عمليه
اخلاء قصريه
للمواطنين الفلسطينيين سكان
جنين اذا نشاهد مقاطع لهم
للاطفال ايضا وهم يخرجون في هذه الساعات
ويتوجهون مجبرين الى اماكن اخرى تاركينا
منازلهم وهذه الصور ايضا نشاهدها مباشره
اذا من جنين فتيا يقومون برمي الحجاره على
هذه المدرعات التي تقتحم هذا المحور
الشرقي لمخيم جنين الياس عندما جرى الحديث
عن هذه العمليه ما جرى التصريح به بانها
قد زجى بقرابه تقريبا الالف جندي من اجل
اتمام هذه العمليه
في عمليه التبديل ما هي المعطيات التي
لديك او التي يمكن توقعها او يجري الحديث
عنها داخل الاعلام الاسرائيلي عن عدد
القوات الموجوده حاليا ضمن معطى الالف
جندي حاليا موجوده وهي تقوم بالعمليات
داخل جنين ومخيمها
وهي تدفع بمزيد من القوات حقيقه ليس واضحا
بعد فيما اذا كانت هذه القوات ستاتي
لمسانده القوات الموجوده والتي تعمل منذ
اكثر من 20 ساعه في داخل المخيم ام ان
الهدف هو اراحه القوات التي عملت منذ فجر
يوم امس وحتى هذه الساعه
وتعزيز القوات العسكريه بادخال قوات لم
تشارك في العمليات القتاليه طيله الساعات
وهذا يمنح قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تفوقا
نوعيا في هذا السياق على اعتبار انه الان
يزج بجنود لم يقاتلوهم مرتاحون
وامامهم ساعات طويله ربما من القتال فيما
ان المقاتلون الفلسطينيون محاصرون في داخل
المخيم هنالك ضغط جديد عليهم منذ ساعات
الفجر وهم طبعا في حاله من المحاصره في
حاله من الملاحقه من جانب قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومن تكثيف النيران لكن الواضح
بان اجلاء السكان الفلسطينيين من المخيم
واجبارهم على ترك بيوتهم هذا يخدم احد اهم
اسس هذه العمليه العسكريه من وجهه النظر
الاسرائيليه وهو عمليا بالا بان تحاول
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بان لا توقع قتل
في صفوف المدنيين الفلسطينيين غير
المسلحين لان وقوع قتلى وجرحى بالعشرات في
صفوف الفلسطينيين قد يؤذي صوره اسرائيل
وقد يؤذي استمرار هذه العمليه العسكريه
واستمرارها على اعتبار ان قتلى وجرحى قد
يجر ايضا ضغطا دوليا كبيرا على اسرائيل
وهي تريد ان تتجنب هذا من اجل استكمال
اهداف عملياتها العسكريه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان اهداف العمليه
العسكريه لم تتحقق كلها حتى هذه الساعه
وانه ربما القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تحتاج على الاقل 24 ساعه اضافيه لاستهداف
كل اهداف هذه العمليه او الاستكمال اهداف
كل هذه العمليه التي حددت لها مسبقا معنا
الياس كرامه وايضا سم
ير ام اذهب الى نابلس ينضم اليه من هناك
دكتور حسن ايوب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه النجاح الوطنيه دكتور حسن ايوب
عندما تقول
اسرائيل بان اهداف العمليه لم تحقق كلها
وتذهب الى تمديد هذه العمليه من حيث
توقعاتك ما هو ما هي الخطوات التاليه
للقوات الموجوده داخل جنين
مساء الخير اولا هذه العمليه العسكريه
تتجاوز ما يمكن اعتباره استعاده قوه الرد
الاسرائيلي مثلما يتم تداول ذلك على
النطاق واسع هي تذهب ابعد من الردع نحو
تفكيك بنيه المقاومه واعطاء درس قاسي لكل
فلسطيني يحاول ان
يتماهى مع النموذج الذي تقدمه مدينه جنين
ومخيم جنين وثانيا تسعى اسرائيل لاحداث
صدمه على نطاق واسع في اوساط الفلسطينيين
وربما هذا ما يفسر قيام قوات الاحتلال
ولاول مره منذ سنوات طويله جدا ربما منذ
عام 67 بترحيل الفلسطينيين من قلب مخيم
جنين بالمئات وربما بالالاف وذلك بضغط
مباشر من القوات التي دخلت الى مخيم جنين
والتي تحتل الكثير من المباني ثالثا تريد
اسرائيل ان تعزز فكره فصل
الجبهات المقاومه عن بعضها البعض وتحديدا
بعد ان نجحت الى حد كبير في
تصفيه الى حد بعيد ظاهره عرين الاسود في
في مدينه نابلس وافقادها القدره على
الحركه والقدره على الفعل المؤثر وايضا
فصل المقاومين عن حواظنهم الشعبيه فصل
المقاومين عن الناس
وايضا يعني يمكن اعتبار ذلك بمثابه رساله
واضحه لكل الفلسطينيين بانه ليس هناك من
يمكن ان يشكل حمايه للفلسطينيه لا السلطه
الفلسطينيه ولا الفصائل ولا المجتمع
الدولي ولا المحيط العربي وبالتالي هذا
سيعمق الشعور الذي تريد ان تتركه اسرائيل
عند الفلسطينيين بالهزيمه وبعدم القدره
على مواجهه المصير المحتوم بقبول ما صرح
به نتنياهو منذ يومين فقط وهو انه لن يكون
للفلسطينيين لا دوله ولا حق تقرير المصير
عليهم ان لا يحلموا بذلك واقصى اليه
اسرائيل
ولكن
انا سؤالي كان يعني في المعطى المعلن بان
سيجري التمديد هذه العمليه اي يعني
المفهوم بان هناك كان سقف لهذه العمليه
كان هناك هدف وهذا الهدف لم يحقق برايك
لماذا لم تحقق اسرائيل قوات الاحتلال بكل
هذا الزاج من قوات بريه ومدرعات وسلاح
الجو هذه النتائج المرجوه من هذه العمليه
خلال 24 ساعه وهي بحاجه لتمديد كما تقول
24 ساعه اخرى على الاقل
نعم اولا اسرائيل لم تحدد سقفا زمنيا
للعمليه منذ بدايه العمليه كان هناك حديث
متواتر عن انه لا يوجد لا اسم ولا سقف
زمني ولا ولم تعلن اسرائيل بشكل واضح حتى
للشريك الامريكي لم تبلغه اسرائيل بشكل
قاطع بسقف زمني لهذه العمليه هذه العمليه
متدحرجه سيتم اشتقاق الاهداف الميدانيه
منها تبعا لتطور حاله المقاومه في داخل
المخيم وتبعا لعوامل اخرى يمكن ان تبرز في
في اطار المواجهه الشامله في مختلف
المناطق الفلسطينيه حيث ربما تتطور
مواجهات في مواقع اخرى شاهدنا اليوم
مظاهرات واشتباكات في اكثر من مكان في
الضفه الغربيه لذلك اسرائيل بتقديري لا
زالت تعتبر انها في المرحله الاولى من هذه
العمليه التي تهدف الى ما يمكن ان نصفه
بتقشير المحيط الذي تتمدرس فيه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في جنين للاستفراد بالمقاومين
بالطريقه التي تمكن اسرائيل من قتل اكبر
عدد من المقاومين باقل عدد ممكن من
الخسائر في صفوف القوات الاسرائيليه لذلك
هي حرصت على ان تمارس ضغط مباشر على
السكان في مخيم جنين لكي يتم خروج اعداد
كبيره منهم لتقديم صوره عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه فعلا حريص على عدم المس
بالمدنيين علما بان ذلك يعني يذكرنا
بمشاهد النكبه الفلسطينيه والنكسه
الفلسطينيه وهو يندرج في اطار الجرائم
التي ترتكبها اسرائيل بحق الفلسطينيين في
اكثر من من مكان لكنه يعني يمثل سابقه لم
تحدث منذ سنوات طويله جدا
للجوء الى لمثل هذا التكتيك الذي من شانه
ان يحرم المقاومين من حاضنتهم الشعبيه
المباشره في داخل مخيم جنين ذاته ستبقى
معنا دكتور
حسن ايوب
وكانت مئات العائلات من مخيم جنين وصلت
لمقر بلديه جنين ومستشفيات المدينه بعد ان
ارغمهم جيش الاحتلال على مغادره المخيم
تحت تهديد قصف منازلهم واقل الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني انه ان تواقمه قامت باجلاء اكثر
من 500 عائله من المخيم رغم الدمار الذي
لحق بالطرق نتيجه تدميرها من اليات جيش
الاحتلال
كلها
طلع اولاد
[موسيقى]
هذا ويحاكي مشهد جنين اليوم مشاهد كثيره
جرت من قبل في نابلس وغزه وغيرها من
المواجهات بين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
وفي كل مره كان يصار الى توصيف ما يجري
على انه تصعيد يجب تفاديه دون التبرع باي
حلول سياسيه للصراع المتطاول والذي اخذ
منحا خطيرا بهذا الاقتحام وبتصريحات رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي من قبل بتصميمه على
الغاء فكره الدوله الفلسطينيه تماما ما
الحل تقرير فوزي بشرى
مخيم جنين في اقصى شمال الضفه الغربيه هنا
اول قلاع المقاومه الفلسطينيه من جهه
الشمال واكثرها صمودا في وجه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
فمخيم جنين الذي يسكنه نحو سبعه وعشرين
الف فلسطيني هو اكبر مخيم للاجئين في
الضفه الغربيه بعد مخيم بلاطه كان دائما
هدفا للاقتحامات الاسرائيليه بحثا عن
الاسلحه وعن من تصفهم اسرائيل بالارهابيين
منذ الساعات الاولى لفجر الاثنين كان
المخيم ساحه للمواجهه التي عاده لا تتكافؤ
فيها القوه لا عددا ولا عتادا بين قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبين شباب المخيم
الذين ربما تفوقوا على عدوهم عزما وتصميما
على حمايه مخيمهم وعلى التصدي لمشروع يبدو
اكبر من قدرتهم على وقفه
رغم وقوفهم بجساره في وجهي بالرغم مما
توافر له من قوه ومن مظله حمايه دوليه
فالعالم لا يبذل للفلسطينيين في احسن
احواله الا التعاطف الخطابي المنذر كل مره
من خطوره ما يسميه بالتصعيد في مخيم
الجنين يتكرر التاريخ بشكل ماساوي فالذين
يتصدون للعدوان الاسرائيلي اليوم ثم كانوا
اجنه او اطفالا للاباء الذين تصدوا له في
عام 2002 فيما وصف يومها بالمجزره التي
سقط فيها العشرات شهداء
ويثير الاعتداء الاسرائيلي على مخيم جنين
الاسئله القديمه حول المشروع الوطني
الفلسطيني ومازيقه فمشهد الجنين كونه
موضوعا لغطرسه القوه الاسرائيليه يبدو كما
لو انه مشهد مقتطع من سيره فلسطينيه
متطاوله على مدى عقود كان خلالها الانسان
والارض كلاهما موضوعا للمحو والالغاء
بالقوه فما يجري في جنين اليوم
حدث من قبل في نابلس وبعدوانيه ووحشيه اشد
حدث في غزه عبر اربع حروب سقط فيها الاف
الشهداء والجرحى ما حيله المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ازاء كل هذا
المقاومه التي تتقاسمها الجغرافيا بين غزه
والضفه وكانت تتقاسمها الفصائليه التي
تضرب مستمعه وتاره فرادى رغم توحدها في
مشروع بدا من وجهه نظر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه يسورا وملهما وهو ما عرف بعرين
الاسود العابر للجغرافيا والمتجاوز
للفصائل لكنه لم يخرج بعد من حالته
الجنينيه ليكون حركه تستوعب كل ما هو
موجود في الساحه الفلسطينيه كما اثبتت
معارف دينين وغزه مؤخره وسؤال المقاومه
يحيل الى سؤال المشروع الوطني الفلسطيني
كله ما مستقبله وما ادواته فهذا المشروع
لا يزال على الاقل في بعده الرسمي اسير
عمليه سلميه كف المجتمع الدولي لاسيما
الامريكيون عن رعايتها فضلا عن التعاطي
معها حتى صارت قيدا لطلاقه الفعل
الفلسطيني التحرري وصارت اي السلطه
الفلسطينيه الموسوعه المقابله لفكره
المقاومه التي كثيرا ما جرمت من قبل
السلطه ومن العالم معه يحدث هذا وقد بلغ
المشروع الاستيطاني ذروته من حيث تمدده
ومن حيث خطابه مع صعود اليمين الاسرائيلي
وعلو نبره الخطاب الصهيوني الديني المهود
للقدس المنتهك والمدنس باستمرار للمسجد
الاقصى
يلتقط رئيس وزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو سانحه انصرا ف العالم الى شؤونه
الاكثر الحاحا ومستغلا غياب مشروع وطني
فلسطيني مجمع عليه في اهدافه وفي وسائله
ليعلن عن تصميمه القضاء على فكره الدوله
الفلسطينيه تماما اما غلاه الصهيونيه
الدينيه كوزير الماليه تيمورتش فيتطلعون
الى دوله اسرائيليه تطلب من الارض ما هو
اكبر من الضفه الغربيه
وللكثيرين يبدو الاعتداء على مخيم جنين
الصامد بروفه اولى لما تعتزمه اسرائيل في
المستقبل وهو بهذا المعنى يصلح ان يكون
تنبيها قويا للفلسطينيين ان اشياء كثيره
في مشروعهم الوطني بحاجه الى مراجعات
جذريه قبل فوات الاوان وقبل جنين اخرى
من جانبها اعلنت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه وقفا
كل الاتصالات واللقاءات مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي مع استمرار وقف تنسيق الامني
وطالب الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس خلال
اجتماع طارق للقياده الفلسطينيه في رام
الله المجتمع الدولي بتوفير الحمايات
العاجله للشعب الفلسطيني وادانه العدوان
الاسرائيلي
ردد من الطالبتنا للمجتمع الدولي
بوجوب توفير الحمايه الدوليه العاجله
لشعبنا
وفرض العقوبات على كيان الاحتلال
وادانت هذا العدوان الارهابي
وقد وجهت الحكومه
واجهزتها ان توفر كل ما يلزم من اجل تعزيز
صمود اهلنا في جنين
وبقيت ارض دوله فلسطين
في هذه اللحظات الصعبه
ادعو ابناء شعبنا الى الصمود والثبات
وتوعد نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس بدوره صالح العروري توعد اسرائيل برد
شامل لا تتوقعه في حال تخطط الخطوط
الحمراء في مخيم جنين وقال العروري في
تصريح للجزيره نقياده الحركه تقيم الموقف
لحظه بلحظه وتضع امامها الاحتمالات كافه
تم ابلاغ
العدو من خلال الوسطاء ان المقاومه في غزه
جزء من شعبنا الفلسطيني وفي حال ارتكاب
هذا العدو لحماقه او تجاوزوا للخطوط
الحمراء فسيجد نفسه في احتمالات مفتوحه
ليس فقط غزه والضفه لكن الامور ممكن ان
تخرج عن السيطره وعن التقدير لو عاد العدو
الى ما فعله في سنه 2002 في مخيم جنين
فالمؤكد انه ستكون معركه واسعه شامله اكبر
مما يتوقع العدو
من جانبه قال محمد الهندي نائب الامين
العام لحركات الجهاد الاسلاميه ان العمليه
الاسرائيليه في جنين تعكس المازق الكبير
الذي تمر به اسرائيل واكد في تصريحات
للجزيره ان المقاومه موحده وتملك بعض
الامكانيات ولديها اراده التصدي
كل الخيارات مفتوحه يعني هذا الشعب
الفلسطيني شعب واحد في كل الاماكن تواجده
سنين جزء من الشعب الفلسطيني المقاومه في
في جنين سرايا القدس في جنين هي جزء من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وجزء ولا يتجزا ولذلك
كل الخيارات مفتوحه على كل احتمالات
والان هناك يعني تقييم
ساعه بساعه لما يدور في جنين
والسرايا الجهاد الاسلامي فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه جميعا متوافقه وبينها تفاهمات
وان شاء الله سيكون هناك تقييم لهذه
العمليه لهذا الاعتداء لهذه الجريمه
وستوقف الجميع امام مسؤولياته
هذا وقال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا اليوم
عمليه واسعه على ما وصفه باهداف ارهابيه
في جنين لوضع حد لها وتصفيتها
جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي بدا اليوم عمليه
واسعه ضد اهداف ارهابيه في جنين في الاشهر
الاخيره تحولت جنين الى ملجا للارهابيين
نحن نضع اليوم حدا نهائيا لذلك قواتنا
دخلت الى اوكار الارهابيين في جنين
لتصفيتهم ويعتقدون المطلوبين ويدمرون
القيادات ويستحودون على السلاح وسوف
يقومون بتدمير مختبرات لانتاج المتفجرات
والعبوات الناسفه معده لقتل الاسرائيليين
كل هذا تقوم به قواتنا في احد الاماكن
الاكثر اكتضاضا على وجه الارض هم يقومون
بذلك باقل الاضرار على المدنيين غير
المتورطين وهذه هي التعليمات الاهتمام
بامن قواتنا والامتناع عن المساس
بالابرياء
دوري قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان
القوات الاسرائيليات تعمل في قلب مخيم
جنين وان العمليه تسير وفق ما هو متوقع
لها واضاف ان من يمس امن اسرائيل لن يكون
له مكان امن وسنصل اليهم جميعا حسب قوله
خذ سالبه القوات الجيش الاسرائيلي وجهاز
الشباك يعملون في قلب مخيم جنين مستعينين
بقوات جويه هذه العمليه تسير وفق ما هو
متوقع لها اعيد واكرر ان كل من يحاول
المساس باسرائيل ومواطنيها وجنودها لن
يكون له مكان امن لا في غزه ولا في نابلس
ولا جنين ايضا سنصل اليهم وسنقدمهم
للعداله او السجن او المقبره لن يكون
بمقدورهم المساس بمواطن اسرائيل
ينضم الينا من حيث دكتور سليم بريك
المحاضر في العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
المفتوحه في حيفاوه الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه دكتور سليم مرحبا بك معنا
يدعو تحرنوت نقلت عن مصادر قبل قليل بان
جيش الاحتلال
يبدا منه نحو الف جندي المرحله الثانيه من
عمليه جنين خلال ساعات المقبله ما هي
الاهداف التي يمكن ان تتوقعها في المرحله
الثانيه
مساء الخير
يعني من ناحيه عمليه من ناحيه تنفيذيه
بالنسبه للجيش اولا استنفاف كل المعلومات
الاستخباريه الموجوده الان بحوزه الجيش
القائل القبض على اكبر عدد ممكن من
الفلسطينيين ليس فقط للردع وانا لا اعرف
ما معنى كلمه الرد يعني في هذا السياق
غير قابل للقياس ولكن ايضا استنتاج
معلومات استخباريه جديده طبعا هذا نهيك عن
تمشيط المنطقه بشكل مطلق والقضاء على كل
المركبات مثلا ادوات موجوده هناك متفجرات
المعامل
كل هذه الامور ولكن الفارق بهذه العمليه
وباعتقاده فعلا هي بحاجه يوم كامل اضافي
حسب سمعنا الجيش هي ايضا خلق نوع من
الترهيب في
المجتمع الفلسطيني في جنين يعني نحن راينا
ارتفاع في درجه رده الفعل الاسرائيليه هي
لم تعد
باطلاق النار او
الاعتقالات وانما ايضا الان في الترحيل
الترحيل من البيوت له معنى سيكولوجي عميق
لانه يربط الفلسطيني بما حدث في النكبه 48
وباعتقادي انه هذه شيء مخطط له هذا شيء
عميق بالتخطيط الاسرائيلي بالتخطيط عند
ناخذ في الاسبان اسلوب تعامله مع
الفلسطينيين الذي يختلف عن وزراء الدفاع
سابقين وباعتقاد ان هذا نوع من التهديد
والترهيب اللحظي ايضا قضيه حجم البنى
التحتيه هذا نوع من العقاب الجماعي هدم
البنى التحتيه الماء الكهرباء كل هذه
الامور اي ان المواطنين العزه اللي يجب ان
يدفعوا ثمن باهظ لمقاومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حتى ولو لم يقل هذا
بوقوع الشهداء مدنيين نعم على السيكولوجيه
الفلسطينيين في جنين وفي المخيم عن طريق
اعطائه مثل هذه الصور المعادله لنكبه 48
والاخلاء وعمليات الترهيب ولكن المتحدث
ايضا باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان
تقارير عن امرنا باخلاء مخيم جنين من
سكاني غير صحيحه هل هذا يندرج ايضا ضمن
اللعبه الاعلاميه النفسيه
اعتقادي نعم اولا هنا توجد حرب نفسيه
[موسيقى]
ان يلعب هذا الدور ونحن نرى
البيوت نحن نرى
للاستعمالها للقناصه نحن نرى الجرافات نرى
كل هذه الامور يعني
هذا ليس بحاجه الى
الى تخطيط بعيد المدى
كما يعتقد البعض القضيه طبعا يجب ان ناخذ
في الحسبان التفاصيل كلها صارت معروفه
سمعنا الكثير من الصباح بكل هذه اكثر من
22 ساعه من العمليه ولكن يجب ان ننظر الى
الصوره الشموليه والمعالم في الطريق
2017 ترامب الذي حاول القضاء على القضيه
الفلسطينيه 2018 قانون القوميه الذي يحول
اسرائيل لدوله حاكمه من البحر الى النهر
وعمليا تلغي السلطه الفلسطينيه وطبعا تلغي
اتفاقيات اوسلو بشكل كامل الان هذه
العمليات في الجنين لارغام الفلسطينيين
الفكره بان لا يوجد مستقبل للفلسطينيين
الا تحت حكم اسرائيل
وعمليا حتى رد الفلسطيني الان صحيح انه
صحيح حاليا ولكنه اتى متاخر جدا لان
السلطه الفلسطينيه بنظر الحكومه الحاليه
الاسرائيليه وصلت الى نهايه الطريق هنا
يوجد نقاش طبعا على مستويين نقاش على
مستوى انه لا يوجد اي مكان لرموز سلطه
فلسطينيه مثلا ما يقول الصهيون الصهيونيه
الدينيه وقسم من اللكود وهناك من يحاول
الان وسمعت هذا طبعا من بعض ضباط الجيش
الان
والاستراتيجيين يقولون بان تجربه سعد حداد
في جنوب لبنان ممكن ان نقوم بها ايضا
بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه اي انه هناك
خلاف بين بعض
المحللين العسكريين وضبات الجيش وبين
الحكومه بكل ما يتعلق باضعاف السلطه
الفلسطينيه لان الحكومه بقياده نتنياهو
ارادت اضعاف السلطه فاصله للنهايه هم
يقولون لا يجب الان اضعاف حماس بشكل قوي
والجهاد الاسلامي لكي تعود السلطه
الفلسطينيه لمكانتها وبهذه الطريقه نحولها
لدرع واقي للاحتلال الاسرائيلي باعتقادي
هذا هو المخطط الخطير الذي تفكر فيه هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بالقياده
اذا هذه الرؤيه ربما الابعد كما تحدث
دكتور سليم بريك ولكن من خلال هذه العمليه
هي تحاول يعني تغيير الواقع الامني في
الضفه الغربيه مع ظهور كتيبه جنين وهذا
الشغل الموحد للفصائل ضمن هذه الكتيبه
وايضا نابلس وعرين الاسود وايضا العمليات
الاخرى في الضفه والمناطق الداخل هل
تستطيع
انجاز مثل هذا الواقع الامني الجديد من
خلال هذه العمليات
تحليل اهداف او الاهداف الفوريه لهذه
العمليه طبعا تقول بان اغلب العمليات التي
قامت ضد اسرائيل ضد المستوطنات اتت من
جنين او ان الذين قاموا بها هربوا الى
جنين ولذلك يجب ان
نقوم القضيه الثانيه طبعا التغير النوعي
في في جنين نحن راينا مثلا اسقاط مسيرات
اسرائيليه تفجير حامله جنود كل هذه الامور
التي هي غير مسبوقه ولكن في نهايه المطاف
حتى كبار الجيش في اسرائيل يدركون بان هذا
لا ينهي
الخطر الامني هذا لا يؤدي في نهايه المطاف
الى زياده من الحمل اسرائيل بالعكس هناك
من يفكر وبجديه بانه بعد هذه العمليه
ستكون عمليات انتقام فلسطينيه ثم ستقول
ستكون عمليات انتقام اسرائيليه وهذا
سيؤدي الى التدهور الاوضاع ولكن عامل
الوقت هو هام جدا
لذلك بانهم يقيسون هذا
هذه الحمله بالساعات كي لا تنتقل النار
الى باقي المناطق الفلسطينيه اولا وثانيا
لكي لا يكون هناك ضغط كبير زياده عن
اللازم على السلطه الفلسطينيه لان هناك
من قبل الكثيرين وطبعا
غطاء امريكي هو ليس غطاء لا نهائي لهذه
العمليه اي ان هذا التنسيق ايضا محدود في
الاهداف وعلى ما يبدو ان الولايات المتحده
وضعت بعض الخطوط الحمراء الاسرائيلي خصوصا
بما يتعلق بالمدنيين ولكن ليس بكل ما
يتعلق بهدم البنى التحتيه او ملاحقه
المسلحين الفلسطينيين وكل هذه الامور على
المبدو ان هناك اسرائيل لها يعني قدره على
التحرك وهي تريد ان تستنفذ هذه العمليه
بافضل ما يمكن شكرا لك دكتور سليم بريك
المحاضر في العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
المفتوحه في حيفا والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
اظهر مقطع فيديو تعرض مستشفى الامل في
جنين لاطلاق نار من جانب قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما تسبب بوقوع اضرار ماديه
ظهر مقطع فيديو عربات عسكريه لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهي تمنع طواقم
الاسعاف الفلسطينيه من الدخول الى حاره
الدمج في جنين لنقل المصابين
انضموا الينا من جنين محمود السعدي مدير
الاسعاف والطوارئ في الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني سيد محمود مرحبا بك معنا ضعنا
في اخر المعلومات المتوفره لديكم عن اعداد
الشهداء والجرحى
الاولى
واعداد المصابين والجرحى
بازدياد في مخيم جنين
تراكمنا العامل في الميدان استطاعت لغايه
هذه اللحظه التعامل على ما يزيد عن 105
اصابات طبعا هذه الاصابات تنوعت بطبيعتها
اصابات كانت في الاطراف العلويه والاطراف
السفليه في الرصاص الحي
والشظايا
وهناك كان تنوع في الاصابات من حيث بعض
الاصابات اتت من عن طريق القصف الجوي الذي
كان من قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
التي قصفت عده مباني داخل المخيم مما ضاعف
عدد الاصابات بشكل سريع
واصيبت وكذلك الشهداء نحن تعاملنا مع سبعه
شهداء تم نقلهم بواسطه
طواقم الهلال الاحمر
وقبل قليل وانا انتظر
المقابله مع حضرتك
ولكن اريد ان انوه ساتابع معك تبقى معنا
نستمع اذا هناك مكبرات صوت هذه اصوات
تاتينا مباشره وهناك دعوات بمكبرات الصوت
لمواجهه قوات الاحتلال اذا مكبرات الصوت
تنطلق منا
مساجد جنين
لمواجهه قوات الاحتلال التي يبدو بانها
تتجهز لمرحله ثانيه وقامت بالزج بمجموعه
اخرى من الجنود نستمع نستمع
[موسيقى]
اذا النداءات تنطلق من مكبرات الصوت في
جنين من المساجد الصوت غير واضح صوت غير
واضح ولكن ما استطعت التقاطه بانه يعني
تجري دعوه السكان لمغادره المنازل توجه
الى المساجد خاصه في الاماكن التي يشعر
سكانها بانهم مهددون وقد تشد عمليات لجيش
الاحتلال
هناك سنعود ربما لهذه الدعوات التي تطلق
عبر مكبرات الصوت في جنين في هذه الليله
العصيبه واعود لمدير الهلال الاحمر معنا
من جنين سيد محمود السعدي ما اكثر ما
يقلقكم في مثل هذه الظروف سيد محمود
وانت تتحدثين عن مكبرات الصوت
قبل قليل كان هنالك تعزيز حشودات عسكريه
اسرائيليه اضافيه الى منطقه جنين ومخيم
جنين
ان ضل ذلك على شيء يدل على ان هناك
ما زالت الحمله
باشرسها ومزاد الحمله قائمه وممكن ان
تستمر عده ايام
لا هذا شيء التعزيزات هذه مباشر لا يبشروا
بالخير
واعتقد ان
الاوضاع الصعبه ستزداد داخل المخيم من حيث
نقل الاصابات ونقل المرضى والحالات
الطارئه التي تستدعي نقل
حالات الانسانيه من داخل المخيم
دافع بهذه التعزيزات حقيقه
لا يبشر بالخير ونحن نعمل جاهدين على ان
نكون جاهزين لاي طارئ لا سمح الله
كنتم قمتم باجلاء يعني اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف اذا من
الفلسطينيين
بصعوبه هذا ما تحدث به الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطينيه ما نوع الصعوبات التي تكتسي
عملكم في مثل هذه الساعات الصعبه في
الميدان
طبعا نحن قمنا بالتعامل مع حالات كانت
معظمها التي تم نقلها عن الاصابات كان
هناك حالات مرضيه
مثل كبار السن الذين كانوا يعانون من ازمه
قلبيه وامراض الضغط والسكري وحالات
عدد من الحالات الولاده التي تم التعامل
معها
الى المشافي القريبه
الصعوبات والعقبات التي تعترض طريق
الطواقم الطبيه التحديدا مركبات الاسعاف
هي ما قامت به قوات الاحتلال من عمليات
تجريف داخل المخيم
والمنطقه المحيطه بالمخيم حيث قامت بتدوير
البنيه التحتيه للشوارع الرئيسيه مما احال
وصول الطماطم الطبيه الى المخيم ومما منع
من التراكم من التحرك بحريه ونقل الاصابات
وعمليات الحفر والسواتر الترابيه التي تم
احاطتها بالمخيم
واغلاق كل المداخل حدت من الطواقم من
الوصول لهذه
لتلك الاصابات التي موجوده داخل المخيم
شكرا لك من جديد محمود السعدي مدير
الاسعاف والطوارئ في الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني
في ردود الفعل العربيه اذا ما يجري في
جنين دانه الخارجيه المصريه الاعتداء
الاسرائيليه على جنين واكدت الرفض الكامل
للاقتحامات المتكرره لمدن فلسطينيه
واعتبرت الخارجيه المصريه الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه للمدن الفلسطينيه
والشرعيه الدوليه من جهتها حذرت الخارجيه
الاردنيه من استمرار دوامه العنف في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ودعت المجتمع
الدولي للتحرك فورا لوقف الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه على الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله ودانت الخارجيه القطريه ايضا باشد
العبارات تكرار عدوان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على مدينه جنين ومخيمها
قال نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده فرحان حق انه يجب على اسرائيل
تنفيذ عملياتها الامنيه بطريقه تتجنب وقوع
اصابات في صفوف المدنيين وتدمير البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه واكد حق ان المنظمه
الدوليه ترغب في وقف جميع الهجمات على
المناطق السكنيه
اما في ردود الفعل الدوليه فقد دعت
الخارجيه الامريكيه الى ضروره اتخاذ جميع
الاجراءات الاحترازيه لمنع ازهاق ارواح
المدنيين في جنين وكان البيت الابيض قال
انه يراقب الوضع في الضفه الغربيه عن كثب
وانه يدعم حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها
وقال المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض انهم
طلعوا على تقارير بشان الوضع ويؤيدون
ابناء اسرائيل وحقها في الدفاع عن شعبها
ضد حماس والجهاد الاسلامي وما وصفها
بالجماعات الارهابيه الاخرى
جهتها عبرت القنصليه البريطانيه في القدس
عن قلقها البالغ ازاء الوضع في جنين وضعت
اسرائيل الى الالتزام بمبادئ الضروره
والتناسب عند الدفاع عن مصلحتها الامنيه
المشروعه واوضحت انه يجب اعطاء الاولويه
لحمايه المدنيين وان من الضروري ضمان وصول
العاملين في الرعايه الطبيه
انضموا الينا من واشنطن بريتس بروين مدير
التعاون السابق في البيت الابيض خلال
اداره الرئيس باراك اوباما سيد بريت مرحبا
بك معنا كيف نفهم الموقف الامريكي الذي
طالما يتحدث عن حق اسرائيل في الدفاع
المشروع عن نفسها ضد من تصفهم بالجماعات
الارهابيه خاصه مع حديث اسرائيلي بانه جرى
اطلاع الجانب الامريكي يعني عن انها ذاهبه
على هذه اللي مثل هذه العمليات دون تفاصيل
ربما
[موسيقى]
اقل عسكريه لهذا الوضع حين ذاك سوف نرى
المزيد من الضغوطات الامريكيه تمارس سواء
على او بطريقه خاصه او سريه هذا ما يجب ان
اتنبه له في الايام المقبله اذا استمر
الوضع سنرى ما ستقوم ستقولها الاداره
الامريكيه
يعني افهم منك بانه مثلا الاداره
الامريكيه الان اداره بايدن هي تقبل ذهب
اسرائيل مثل هذه العمليه العسكريه
يعني يعني هناك موافقه على الاقل
لعمليه عسكريه يعني موافقه امريكيه وبصمه
امريكيه مثلا
لا اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن بصمه اسرائيل بصمه
امريكيه عفوا ولكن نرى ان الولايات
المتحده قد
تتيح بعض الهامش للقاده الاسرائيليين لكي
يبداوا ما يعتبرونه عمليه للدفاع عن النفس
ولكن طبعا هذا العمليه قد ازعقت ارواح
ثمانيه اشخاص
كم بدات العديد من الاصابات واذا استمرت
هذا الاصابات والوفيات بالارتفاع سوف نرى
المزيد من الدعوه من قاده في الغرب وفي
العالم
لكي تضبط اسرائيل نفسها واعتقده في عجاله
اذا يعني حتى ولو كانت هي ليست بصمه
امريكيه بصمه دعم امريكي على الاقل ولكن
في عجاله كيف يبدو الموقف الامريكي يعني
باتجاه الاستيطان هناك موقف وباتجاه
العمليه هناك موقف اخر باتجاه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه موقف ثالث
ماذا ماذا هناك
من المهم ان لا ننسى هنا
ان رئيس الوزراء نتانيا قد خسر الكثير من
الدعم لدى البيت الابيض وبالتالي لم يعد
لديه اهمش التحرك الذي كان يمتلكه من قبل
او الذي كان يمتلكهما
سبقه وبالتالي الموقف الامريكي سوف يكون
طبعا دائما دعم حق الاسرائيلي او جهد
الاسرائيلي للدفاع عن النفس يجب ان نتنبه
الى مسرح سلفي الايام المقبله لنرى كيف
ستبلور الامور شكرا لك من واشنطن
اشكرك
مدير التعاون الدولي السابق في البيت
الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس السابق باراك
اوباما شكرا على المشاركه معنا من واشنطن
تغطتنا مستمره للعمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في جنين ولكن نتابع الان
اخبارا اخرى حيث قال مصدر عسكري بالجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان طيران الحربي قصف
اكثر من عشر سيارات مسلحات تابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع تحركت من منطقه تمبول وسط
السودان الى الخرطوم من جهه يقال الناطق
الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني ان قياده
الجيش وجهت القيادات العسكريه بضروره
استقبال وتجهيز المقاتلين الذين لبوا نداء
رئيسي مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
القتالي في صفوف الجيش
تخيم اجواء من التواتر في مدن فرنسيه عده
وذلك بعد السته ايام من المواجهات التي
جرت بين قوات الامن ومتظاهرين محتجين على
مقتل شابا جزائري بالرصاصي رجل شرطه
واعلنت داخليه الفرنسيه ايقاف
175 شخصا خلال احتجاجات الليله الماضيه
كما نظم رؤساء البلديات في عموم البلاد
وقفه احتجاجيه امام مقر بلدياتهم للتنديد
بالعنف الذي تشهده مدن عده في البلاد
وطلبوا بتوفير الحمايه لهم
قال وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو ان التمرد
الذي قاده مؤسس شركه فاجنري في الرابع
والعشرين من الشهر الماضي كان محاوله
لزعزعه الاستقرار في البلاد
اكد نائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء ووزير النفط
الكويتي سعد البراك رفض دوله الكويت جمله
وتفصيلا الادعاءات والاجراءات الايرانيه
حيال حقل الذره البحري وشدد الوزير
الكويتي في بيان له على ان حقل الدره هو
ثروه طبيعيه كويتيه سعوديه وليس لاي طرف
اخر اي حق فيه حتى حسم ترسيم الحدود
البحريه وكذا البراك ان الطرفين الكويتي
والسعوديين متفقان تماما كطرفا تفاوضيا
واحد داعيا ايران الى الالتزاء الى
الالتزام اولا بترسيم الحدود الدوليه
البحريه قبل ان يكون لها اي حق في حقل
الدره حسب ما جاء في البيان وكانت
الخارجيه الكويتيه قد جددت في وقت سابق
اليوم دعواتها للجانب الايراني الى البدء
في مفاوضات ترسيم الحدود البحريه بين
الجانبين الكويتي والسعودي كطرف تفوضيا
واحد مقابل الجانب الايراني